and is it this year or next year there's
going to be 20 years since we got
together yeah next year since our first
album came out 20 years I think this is
your first ever photo shoot and bear in
mind this is the photograph they
approved there were worse pictures from
this photo shoot yeah there they are it
seems unlikely that they would be global
superstars at that time we were only
really eating pasties and Mars milk
either you get from the service station
yeah oh that kind of chocolatey meals
yeah and that's all we would eat and we
thought we're gonna look great there's
no problem and we didn't really have
anyone to tell us what to wear what
there wasn't a stylist
yeah we've paid this guy 8,000 person
that would never saw him again look at
Coldplay now and you're kind of you know
gods and you tour the world everything
and you're sitting beside Hugh Grant
yeah you and I know you were a fan I'm a
giant fan of you likewise likewise you
want to see my pattern I said I'm fan
mail as a 40 year old man so recent went
you have recently yeah not so much since
the restraining order but thank you but
every time Hugh is very grumpy
yeah whatever rock star [ __ ] off with
your other half and
so no so about to you it was about it
was after a very British scandal I
thought you know I'm gonna tell you that
I think is wonderful because I've loved
his work ever since he started 45 years
ago I really have and after British
scandal and Paddington - I just thought
I'm I think I just wrote hey I love you
and he replied and it was very gracious
crap or music that's why I I've been you
know I've just I've only got two records
one of them's Godspell and the other one
is the band of the Grenadier Guards
[Applause]
[Music]
you